what I think is fascinating about the
Secret Service in part is that we do see
them unlike CIA agents we see Secret
Service agents doing some of their work
and I think we partly think that we
understand them or know them in reality
theirs is a very complex story a very
complex organization and and yes even
enigmatic as the as the subtitle
suggests Laura asked me to say a little
bit about the the project itself the
project was written almost a year to
this day and it was November 16 that the
actual writing began but you recall that
I had been doing research previously on
the Secret Service for a number of years
and having Peter Stephens to wordsmith
the project of course while I was doing
the other tasks made it go along much
faster than if there was simply one
person working on it
and the the source is used very briefly
one of the rich sources were the memoirs
of Secret Service agents themselves
retired agents and the biographies and
memoirs of ex presidents and their
Chiefs of Staff all of them in one way
or another had something to say about
their interactions with this agency so
that was a good starting point there
were some excellent government reports
that were publicly available believe it
or not and even some from think tanks
like the RAND Corporation analyzing
White House security and talking about
the history of presidential protection I
did use the free of information act to
obtain documents regarding President
Kennedy's assassination and the Secret
Service's protective role therein and
also documents pertaining to the
attempted assassination of President
Ronald Reagan in 1981 and then there
were the interviews which is the richest
part of the book even though the
interviews are not many they are
hopefully very rich the the interviews
with retired agents the interviews with
present agents and the interviews with
politico's White House campaign people
presidential campaign people who worked
on the political trail interacting with
with Secret Service agents
so it is a history from 1865 to the
present but we've pulled out of that
history the successes and failures the
major tragedies and triumphs that the
Secret Service has had from the
assassination of President Kennedy to
what happened to the agency in the wake
of 9/11 and and all of the events along
the way this was difficult in a project
in terms of getting information they
don't call it the Secret Service for
nothing
it is a secretive organization and does
not like to talk about its work does not
like to reveal its methods obviously and
then there is the code which Secret
Service culture refers to the code that
says that X agents and current agents
will not talk about two subjects one is
the personalities and foibles of the
individuals that they protected and
second is how they go about their work
so anyone seeking to get first-hand
information is is confronting the code
and it's it's not an easy code to break
worse for this author however I ran into
double whammy if you will in that this
was in the wake of 9/11 and because of
9/11 the Secret Service was so
overmatched and understaffed that they
virtually gave up talking to the public
in fact in some frustrated moments I
would tell anyone who would listen they
should change the name of their public
affairs office to private affairs or
internal affairs because they weren't
responding to at least this public and
it was very difficult to get information
in fact I had one agent from public
affairs returned a phone call which was
a joy and he candidly told me that if it
wasn't for the fact that I knew somebody
who knew somebody in his office that
this phone call would not be happening
because there wasn't time for it and in
fact he ended up answering about 40% of
the questions that I posed to him he
also said very candidly look everybody
with a badge and a gun in this office
public affairs is out protecting
somebody at this point so I ran into
that problem as well that there was no
functioning public affairs and there was
the the code of silence and all but two
of the agents that I talked to came
networking with other people whether
they retired or present only in two
cases did I approach somebody
successfully who would talk to me as an
author as a political scientist the rest
of it was was pure networking and it was
difficult at that and more agents
declined to talk to me then talk to me
which is of course their perfect right
to do so let me talk a little bit about
the history before getting to the more
current events um the Secret Service was
created in 1865 and it was the last
official act of Abraham Lincoln before
he was assassinated that afternoon
before he went to Ford's Theater to be
assassinated by John Wilkes Booth he met
with the Secretary of Treasury and they
agreed on the creation of the Secret
Service uh now some think that that's a
sad historical irony in the sense that
here's a president about to be
assassinated they create an agency to
protect presidents but it doesn't do
them any good well indeed
the Secret Service was not created to
protect presidents in fact it was
created solely to protect something that
the system may have valued more highly
than the lives of its political leaders
and that is our money counterfeiting
during the Civil War was so endemic that
the the actual currency system was
threatened so that's what the Secret
Service was was formed to do and by the
late eighteen using the late 1860's we
had two dozen swashbuckling agents
running about the country with the guns
that they had purchased on their own
seeking out the counterfeiters and their
their badges if you will their
identification their bona fides
consisted of a letter from the secretary
of the Treasury to each of them saying
so-and-so is a bona fide Secret Service
agent well it didn't take the bad guys
long to catch on to that and one of them
wrote the Secretary of Treasury got a
response lifted the signature put it on
a letter of his own concoction
walked into a Secret Service field
office and essentially said hi as you
can see I'm here at behest of the
Secretary of Treasury open your safe
give me all your seized counterfeit
bills and by the way throwing the good
cash as well and I'll take that back to
Washington fortunately for the service
they discovered the scam before they
opened the vault to this individual but
someone thought it would be a good idea
to issue badges so badges were issued
and in fact there's a very distinctive
five-point shields that are still on the
Secret Service shield and logo today and
agents in 1871 had to purchase their own
badges for twenty-five dollars which was
a lot of money then the good news was
they got the money back when they
retired if they turned in their badges
the is a very colorful history I just
give you some of the headlines the
Secret Service battled the Ku Klux Klan
in the rim states in the immediate
aftermath of the Civil War they were
just a law enforcement agency on hand
who who took up that role they were our
chief spying agency and counter spy
agency in World War one they broke
German spy rings quite successfully they
were what the CIA or the FBI would be
today and and they had that sole
responsibility which they would later
lose and so you might be wondering when
did they start protecting presidents and
candidates and political leaders the
first instance was 1894 and it's very
interesting because it was the head of
the Secret Service himself William Hazen
who on his own decided that he'd heard
some rumblings in Colorado that some
criminal types might have a grudge
against President Cleveland so on his
own he assigned two agents to the
Cleveland White House without asking the
Secretary of Treasury without
congressional authorization the two
agents just showed up well evidently the
first lady thought that was a dandy idea
because that summer of the same year
without telling her husband the
president she went to the Secret Service
and asked them for agents to come to
their summer home which was up the road
here in Marion and to protect the family
especially the children during the
summer because she feared a kidnapping
so when President when the president
showed up at his summer home he was
surprised to find Secret Service agents
but he accepted it now you might think
that given the birth of that idea and
the notion of agents being present
protecting presidents and first families
that it was a linear curve or a straight
line evolution to the present but but
not so
the protected mission evolved in fits
and starts and it was for a long time
not clear that it would be a mission and
it would be their mission for example
Congress elements of Congress had a to
giving agents over to the White House
they worried that it was another
presidential perk that presidents were
going to have some sort of a police
force or an armed force at their
disposal and they just didn't want to do
that they forbid it at certain times in
fact and presidents themselves some of
them weren't always sure they wanted
Secret Service protection imagine warren
g harding when he discovered that the
investigation that brought down his
administration the Teapot Dome scandal
and sent his Secretary of the Interior
to jail was spearheaded by Secret
Service agents and so they were less
than welcome in the Harding White House
after that Franklin D Roosevelt flirted
seriously with the idea of using FBI
agents to protect him instead of Secret
Service agents of course this was at the
the hest of j edgar hoover who wanted
every federal mission to be his and
nobody else's but the president gave
some indications of trying to respond to
that so it wasn't until 1951 that
Congress finally passed the permanent
authorization for the Secret Service
to protect presidents and provided the
the annual funding for it and that
caused Harry Truman to quit quote the
work of protecting me has at last become
legal unquote and the Secret Service is
a dual mission organization it still
does anti counterfeiting and by the way
anti counterfeiting doesn't roll off my
tongue really well so I'm going to talk
about the counterfeiting mission but I
don't intend the image of Secret Service
agents in their basement cranking out
hundred-dollar bills they even call it
the counterfeiting mission they do both
they protect political leaders as
assigned by the president they protect
national security events and they also
protect the currency from electronic
theft as well as duplication not only
does the organization do that but
individual agents do that as well you
are trained to do both
when you undergo training your career
will involve both missions you'll start
three to five years in a field office
doing mostly contra fitting you will
then go into protective work for a
period of years doing that and then go
back to doing counterfeiting so there is
that that dual mission I wanted to
emphasize the politics I think it's it's
certainly very interesting the protected
mission takes place in the political
cauldron that is presidential politics
and the conflict between the protectors
and the politicos is absolutely
inevitable as as I'm sure you can see
the politicos wants the perfect camera
angle the ideal photo shoot they want
the largest crowds possible looking
spontaneous they want the the best
motorcade route that will give them
access they want locations that look
good the protectors want a 360 degree
circle around the president that nobody
could get into except then they want no
spontaneity if they can avoid it they
want the crowds kept back as far as
possible and they want agendas that they
can control so obviously this is a
conflict I mean when you see a Secret
Service agent hanging on to President
Clinton's belt buckle belt from behind
as he greets the crowd that agents going
to be in every photo op where the
president is and the politicos don't
necessarily look like that but what I
discovered is that it's a very
interesting relationship and it's one of
the negotiation that the political
people will tell you they didn't go and
yell at the Secret Service and say look
here's what we have to do they would go
to them and explain and the service
would say the same thing that you didn't
just go to the president of the campaign
and say look cancel that stop or change
this route you said here are five good
reasons why we think it's too dangerous
you know let's negotiate and it is a
negotiated process of course as in any
human process that sometimes breaks down
and I did run into politico's who had
less than kind things to say about
Secret Service agents being fascist
automatons and Secret Service agents who
who would say that some of the people
they protected just were so reckless it
almost seemed as if they didn't care
what happened to them
and there was a lot of that but
basically it was a situation of mutual
respect and negotiation I'm not going to
go through all the crises of the Secret
Service but we want to highlight some of
them can look forward to reading about
them there is of course the the worst
crisis was the JFK assassination the
first time they lost a president since
they had been protecting presidents and
I think the bottom line of that a lot of
research into it is that the Secret
Service was woefully unprepared for that
challenge in terms of the planning of
the event in terms of their reaction in
terms of the procedures that were in
place and they learned from that
certainly and improved greatly but I
have to say by way of footnote that that
learning was somewhat [ __ ] by their
attempts to cover up their ineptitudes
and to cover up what had happened with
regard to their failures to protect the
president but it's a good story the
limit let me continue on if I might the
assassination attempted assassination of
President Reagan in 1981 is the most
recent instructive detailed case that we
have and the good news here is that the
heroic quick thinking of agents at the
crime scene within 10 seconds of the
first shot President Reagan was in the
limousine and on his way to well first
to the White House but then when they
discovered that he was wounded he was on
the way to the hospital and we've all
seen the picture of courageous agent
Timothy McCarthy making himself a large
target and taking a bullet for the
president as he was trained to do as
they all were trained to do so at the
crime scene they did wonderfully in
terms of procedure and reaction the
problems were twofold that after getting
the president safely away there were
failures to back up security there were
failures in communication that if this
had been more than a lone deranged
individual could have put the president
at further risk by leaving him
relatively unprotected and then at the
other end of it there's the question
that needs answering which is how does
it deranged individual with a gun get
within 20 feet of the president
fire six shots and wound four people
before he can be stopped and and there
were certainly failures in that regard
one of the greatest crises of a Secret
Service or at least its culture came not
from guns or bullets but from the
subpoenas of Special Counsel Kenneth
Starr in the Monica Lewinsky case Ken
Starr wanted Secret Service agents to
testify before a grand jury what did
they know what did they see
The Secret Service fought this tooth and
nail all the way to the Supreme Court
agents even came out of their their code
if you will and went on talk shows
retired agents talking about how
devastating this would be they weren't
trying to protect the Clinton presidency
they weren't trying to cover up
criminality their main fright was that
that fragile bond of trust and
confidentiality between the agents and
the people they protect would be
shattered by these subpoenas I mean
simply put they want to be within one to
three two feet of who they're protecting
and if that if the who they're
protecting is gonna think to themselves
I can't listen have them listen to this
conversation with my wife or this
conversation with my manager because it
may end up in court someday move 12 feet
away then they're going to be outside
the zone at which they can do anything
to protect the president they're very
aware of this in fact that kind of worry
had come even before the subpoenas there
were candidates who mistrusted
Washington George Wallace comes to mind
the outsider who mistrusted the
Washington establishment who would tell
the Secret Service to get at a large
distance to keep away from conversations
so they were very worried that this
would happen and the effect is unknown
to us because it's behind the scenes
whether people's memoirs and writings a
decade from now we'll say the bond of
trust remained it didn't seem to be
impinged upon or whether there were a
lot of instances in which candidates are
the presidents said get at a distance we
we just don't know the the last and most
immediate crisis was of course the
terrorist attacks and we
the book spends a good deal of time
analyzing how that affected the service
but let me just say um the Secret
Service can protect anyone that the
president assigns them to that's it the
president can assign anyone protection
and the good news is that that privilege
has not been abused over the years there
has not been a president who said I have
a big contributor that would like to see
what it's like to be protected by the
Secret Service go protect him for the
weekend or somebody in my family would
think it would be fun they haven't done
that and it's been very good but as you
might imagine in the wake of the
terrorist attacks President Bush
massively increased the number of
protech T's that the Secret Service had
to deal with and it we had extended to I
don't have the list because it's
classified but I do know in talking to
people that it certainly extended to the
congressional leadership to Secretary of
State Colin Powell to National Security
Advisor Condoleezza Rice and as one
agent told me almost incredulous ly and
to dr. Rice's assistant so the list had
perhaps doubled even tripled overnight
and as if that weren't a problem enough
we stretched the Secret Service thin by
having anything that the president
defines as a national security event can
be under the aegis of Secret Service
protection so the Super Bowl was under
Secret Service protection the Winter
Olympics in Utah were under Secret
Service protection now that worked
terrifically without incident but but
imagine hundreds of agents securing you
know miles of snow field in Utah with
the bomb sniffing dogs the
counter-sniper teams all of the metal
detectors and these were agents who
might have been doing other work if they
weren't doing that so there's a
tremendous overwork of the agents I
think at some point somebody has to
decide is the Secret Service going to be
involved in every national crisis over
we're going to divide the labor more
they even assign 50 field agents from
the Washington office to the sniper case
which which sounds like it makes sense
and you're doing everything you can to
keep to catch the sniper but you have to
consider where the where the human
resource
are coming from the best estimate that I
could get was that around the time of
the terrorist attacks there were 2,700
Secret Service agents 2,700 today it's
surely more than that but it's not as if
they can conscripted and crank them out
in great volume in John Kennedy's era
there were 300 Secret Service agents so
you could think that a 900 percent
increase sounds good but in John
Kennedy's era the list of protech T's
was already very short and the threats
from terrorists and the the complicated
nature of the world was not nearly at
what it is now and to show you how
stressed they were already it is a
traditional practice in the Secret
Service in presidential campaigns when
there's two or three Republicans running
two or three three or four Democrats
they don't have enough agents to protect
all of these candidates that they borrow
agents from other agencies Alcohol
Tobacco and Firearms customs the IRS
they were already doing that when they
were protecting the the short list
before it was extended in 9/11 the part
of the human factor is the the agents
themselves I need it be said that this
is a very stressful job that an
eight-hour shift at this job may be
unlike many others obviously some in law
enforcement but being ready at a split
second to determine if it's a balloon a
firecracker or a 22 caliber gun being
ready to make that decision about
whether you jump on the protec t not
them down and cover them - everybody's
embarrassment if it's a balloon or do
you wait a second to think about it and
find out that it is a gun and it's too
late standing for hours on fixed duty
waiting for a particular noise or a
particular stimulus scanning the crowds
to look for motion or for eye contact or
for the pictures of people who are on
your list this is very very difficult
work and they do talk about burnout
considerably and that's why there is
some limit to the to the length of
protective duty but I'm not sure what
that limit is they they talk about in
one sense it being limited to three
five years but then some agents and
their memos will say well first I
protected President Carter and then
there was President Reagan and then I
got a little bit into President Bush
number one so so some of them do stay
around for a long time
besides the inherent stress it's a it's
a difficult career to pursue as one
agent told me that the inside joke was
if the Secret Service wanted you to have
a family they would have issued you one
and the other shibboleths are you will
travel and you will relocate and I came
to understand this in the wake of 9/11
when I was at a field office and they
were explaining to me the assignments of
agents and some of them were in Utah and
had been for weeks and some of them were
in the Middle East with a protective
detail of you go where the protectee
goes I mean if you're in President
Clinton's detail and he decides former
President Clinton and he decides he's
going to go to South Africa that's where
you're gonna end up and you don't get to
postpone it because of your daughter's
birthday so all in all it is it is
difficult and I I'm mum there have been
more incidents lately than previously of
agents getting into trouble is the
category I guess and I I certainly the
incidents that happen - a few agents
should not tarnish the whole
organization I'm not suggesting that but
I'm suggesting that the newspapers are
fuller of problems with agents in the
last two or three years than in the
previous ten years you know case of
alleged airline rage that's still being
worked out the tawdry spectacle of
several agents in vice president
Cheney's detail getting into a barroom
brawl with civilians while wearing their
guns and badges and when the police show
up they think that everybody's
intoxicated and these kinds of things
all I'm suggesting is that the Secret
Service should look to its psychological
infrastructure in the wake of their
stress generally and how overstressed
they are now and perhaps try to do
something with that and hopefully they
are the have some recommendations in the
book about how to make the Secret
Service better and one of them I knew
would not fly
see it's okay for professors to visit
the ivory tower once in a while as long
as they don't spend too long there I
knew it wouldn't fly and Anu wouldn't
fly because it went against the
organization's tradition my suggestion
was to take a hard look at whether the
counterfeiting mission should be severed
from the protected mission and put
someplace else in Treasury leaving the
Secret Service to do protective work
exclusively and I knew it wouldn't fly
because that's what they were created to
do it's their tradition and they all
have a mantra of two items whether it's
the former director the current director
all the agents they have a mantra that
has two items about counterfeiting
versus protection and I will gladly
accept the first one but I will
challenge the second one the first one
is anti counterfeiting work is very
professionally rewarding and I'm
prepared to accept that it is of course
in fact I had three agents tell me that
they preferred the counterfeiting work
to the protective work which they found
at times terribly boring at least in
counterfeiting you're moving around you
know it's it's detective work and you're
not standing in a hallway for five hours
staring at the at the walls that I will
accept the second part of it is that the
same skills that make a good anti
counterfeiting agent are the same skills
that will make a good protector quick
reactions very good law enforcement
judgment and there may be something to
that and that they're both law
enforcement and involve guns but I would
submit to you that these are very
different activities that putting a $20
bill under a microscope to see if Andy
Jackson's tie is on straight going
undercover to follow the money trail
breaking into a basement where the
printing press is cranking are very
fundamentally different activities from
standing on the Rope line waiting for
that split second reaction and and
scanning the crowd and I don't think we
would have FBI agents who chase
terrorists or counter terrorists serve
on the Border Patrol for three to five
years I don't think we require Navy
SEALs or Green Berets to invest
crimes that army and navy bases for
three to five years before they went on
to do their hazardous duty so it's
something that needs looking at so I
knew it wouldn't fly and here we get
Homeland Security a bill in which the
most radical reorganization of the
federal government in 50 years is about
to take place and the Secret Service is
one of those 22 agencies that is
proposed to be uprooted from its
traditional bureaucratic home and placed
in the Homeland Security Department and
I've heard nobody talked about leaving
the counterfeiting mission behind so the
most radical bureaucratic change is
taking place without my recommendation
obviously and still it makes so much
sense to leave counterfeiting behind in
Treasury to be done by the Treasury
security force or somebody it belongs in
Treasury and if it ends up in Homeland
Security I think that will have been an
opportunity that was missed in closing
let me just say that I think you can't
look at this organization in detail
these this analyst can't without being
impressed if you think about the the
scandals and the blunders that have
plagued some of the Secret Service's
sister agencies in the federal
government in the last five years that's
not the story here and what when you
look what you see is a an impressive
cadre of well-trained professional
patriotic people who are overworked and
understaffed and sometimes even
underappreciated but do a very good job
thank you
if you would like to ask a question now
is the time to do it but please raise
your hand so that the microphone can
make its way to you
and just pause a minute before you start
okay thank you I believe you said that
you started your research with 1961 why
did you choose that gear no I had
started my interest in the Secret
Service about two decades ago which
would have in the book Oh
in the book it takes the Secret Service
from its inception in 1865 right up to
the post 9/11 and and everything good
and bad that happened to it in that area
I work for Treasury in Washington and as
the Kennedy administration mysteries the
tape which they if came to saturated
I worked closely with Secret Service bro
Peterson who was head of the Secret
Service then I really appreciate your
book
thank you very much appreciate your
comment
soon indeed to observe any of the secret
agents who are here working with
President Clinton recently in New
Bedford no I did not I didn't but I I
know students who did and they told me
some interesting stories but yes a
grammar school history long ago
the idea that Lincoln leaped off the
gallery of the Ford theater to the floor
below always struck me as someone of a
prevarication but I was in the Ford
theater in distance is only about from
that awning over there to that floor it
isn't much so he probably did not sure
no I just say not true I said I didn't
know he was about Ford's Theater and the
physical layout thank you if if I
understood correctly it seemed you were
suggesting that agents kind of
recirculated from the protective service
to counterfeiting and back again from
time to time so that if in some future
time the there's two missions were split
apart and put in separate auspices what
would happen how would the protective
service actually function if as you
suggested agents kind of burn out and
very quickly what would happen to it
that's a very good question they would
have to devise ways which I think are
there to rotate agents in various facets
of the protective mission there are a
lot of things that they could do besides
carrying a gun on the rope line there
there are field offices
there's protective research protective
intelligence there's a lot of things
that could be done and they could be
doing that instead of taking the the
downtime in the counterfeiting mission I
think it would work I think it could be
designed to work
could you say something about the
professional or the educational
background of potential Secret Service
agents with a accountants or police
officers or military previous to going
to see the service ok I'll tell you what
they say and I'll tell you what my my
feeling is they they will tell you and
it's true that they encourage a wide
range of applications and as one Secret
Service director said we can use people
from accounting you mentioned that
specifically even from from art school
so we have something for everybody we
retrain everybody and that's probably
true that among 2,700 agents you could
find a smorgasbord of majors that you
might find at UMass Dartmouth having
said that if you think about it
realistically someone who comes to them
with a law enforcement background or
Special Forces military training of some
kind really has the leg up in the sense
that first of all they've already been
quite well security cleared probably and
secondly they bring to the job a
training that others don't have and
that's not to say that they're becoming
an exclusively paramilitary organization
but I do think that there you have a
preference for some prior experience
although they will take people from
almost every walk of life you will
I'm not sure about the comparative data
the their general proportion of
african-americans in the organization
seems consistent with other agencies
there may be some difference it seems
consistent within the organization
there's debate and conflicting evidence
about what this means for example while
President Clinton's chief chief of his
detail Larry cockerel who is
african-american is now the first
african-american assistant director in
line to possibly come become director so
that looks good and then that's
countered by the suit filed by several
African American agents claiming that
their promotions to the upper ranks of
the bureaucracy were blocked because of
their race they've got both things going
on at once and it's a kind of continuing
story and continuing struggle your
extensive research into the
assassination of Robert Kennedy can't
resist asking a question about the
events that occurred in 1968 it seems to
me that part of the story was that I
believe Roosevelt Grier had been a kind
of volunteer lay bodyguard for Bobby and
was he sufficiently protected by the
Secret Service himself at that time well
no the answer is definitely no because
Secret Service protection of
presidential candidates was extended for
the first time in reaction to Robert
Kennedy's assassination previously there
had been no Secret Service protection of
candidates until you got to be President
there were other modes of protection of
course police and personal bodyguards
but Robert Kennedy did not want uniform
police or private security presence in
his campaign for image reasons and there
was a kind of fatalism in that campaign
whereby there wasn't a heavily armed
cadre of of Kennedy friends and
associates
there was an ex-fbi agent named William
Barry
it's not clear to me whether he
typically was armed or unarmed the
record is unclear on that but he was the
closest thing to a protector that
Kennedy had Roosevelt Grier and Rafer
Johnson were called bodyguards but these
were burly athletes who happened to be
around the scene they weren't
systematically guarding him always has
fascinated me about the Civil War era of
question leading up to Lincoln's
assassination how lakhs or unconcern
there was for protection especially was
one in the country and the access
Lincoln traveling by himself or with his
wife in the carriage certainly they must
have had thought that would be you know
high chances of threats and so forth
what was I thinking back then I I don't
know it's a fascinating point here we
are at war in a civil war at that and
battles are being fought within the
shadow of the White House and and yet
except for troops on the White House
lawn
Lincoln would go about in carriages with
with perhaps only one officer with a gun
it makes no sense to me but one of the
fascinating things that is documented in
the book though is that White House
security now compared to the old days is
quite fascinating I mean they used to
allow an inauguration parties the crowd
used to spill into the White House and
sort of take over and revel for into the
wee hours of the morning and people
would walk in in various administrations
Andrew Jackson and others and come to
the president's office and greet them or
in one case slap them in the face has
happened to President Jackson the amount
of access and lack of protection to our
older presidents is really quite a
fascinating story and one of the
fascinating stories is that except for a
President Lincoln and that tragedy we
had numerous presidents in the old
presidency that that virtually went
through office without incident even
though people could walk on their lawn
and open the door to the White House so
it's a different era this just just
couldn't happen that someone would harm
the president in general I don't know if
there were if I were there and there
were a civil war in hindsight I would be
advising the president to get some
extensive guards I mean it just makes
sense
I have a question about the nature the
relationship between the FBI and the
Secret Service particularly over time
and has it has evolved in your chapter
on the JFK assassination it's pretty
clear that there wasn't a lot of
information sharing has that changed and
you think that that sort of thing will
be helped with the Homeland Security
Department is there going to be more
cooperation between these agencies
there's definitely going to be more
cooperation because the spotlight is on
them and they've been ordered to have
more cooperation and the previous
resistance to cooperation is going to be
tougher for the individual agencies to
pursue so yes there's going to be more
but whether it will be effective is
another open question it's not just
providing data but it's what kind of
data you provide the Secret Service is
dependent on other organizations for its
data it will investigate threats threats
come to it but basically for terrorist
threats it's dependent on the FBI and
the CIA and other agencies and the form
in which that information comes to them
whether it's boiled down or its massive
and they can't read it it's going to be
an important question that probably has
yet to be resolved
good short question is there anything on
your historical data reference of the
Secret Service in John Goffe got not
John Garfield but President Garfield and
it's and more recently the Puerto Rican
nationalists when they try to bag Truman
I was a Truman or who does that one it
yes on the log the wisdom any actuals
I've never heard any feedback from that
in the Intel community as to who did
what what did who whether was how it
went down either with Garfield and or
Truman well the Garfield case in another
historical irony there were two Secret
Service agents at the train station when
Garfield was was assaulted and fatally
wounded but again they weren't doing
presidential protection they were just
on their way to somewhere in the Truman
case mmm that was different in the sense
that clearly that was a conspiracy and a
politically motivated conspiracy you
have two Puerto Rican nationalists
assaulting simultaneously and the
President Truman was never in very much
danger given that the the way things
were set up in the guards that he had at
Blair House but it was one of those few
instances that the Secret Service
historically regards as a conspiracy
because they can't deny that they were
two gunmen coming at once
I happen to be in Providence Airport one
day when Bobby Kennedy was discussing
obviously things with a man on each side
and they were walking down and up and
down they continued that for over half
an hour now anybody with a small gun
could have killed him anybody
oh yes the I mean we were talking
earlier about protection of President
Lincoln the the campaigning style
especially of Robert Kennedy if you've
seen the films here's here's Robert
Kennedy on the back of a limousine
that's moving slowly and his his
entourage is holding him so he won't be
pulled into the crowd people are taking
his cufflinks tousle in his hair it was
as up close as you could possibly get it
was a era a throwback here that we'll
never see again on the campaign trail
for sure given the secrecy of the Secret
Service how much do you think is really
covered up today as like example last
when the the latest sniper case in
Washington there was a little tiny
article in the paper saying that a man
had jumped the fence at the White House
and you know he was quickly caught and
and scurried off and he left I just
wonder how much of that stuff happens
that we don't know about and how much is
covered up by the Secret Service to make
it you know not that they're not doing
the job but to make it seem like
everyone is safe you know that that the
president that is always safe even
though I always find that amazing that
people get into the White House even
during all of that it well that's a good
question they answered it as best I can
the the the Secret Service will not talk
about cases of prevention or instances
unless they have to they sometimes have
to because when somebody jumps the fence
and is arrested it becomes a news item
when somebody takes a pot shot at the
White House then then it's a news item
when somebody tries to crash a plane
into the Clinton White House it's a news
item so then they'll talk about it so we
don't know behind the scenes
I mean I've seen it referred to that
there are several threats a day against
any president so obviously there are
thousands each year and we know that as
we watch the president we fortunately
have not seen an overt attack on the
president United States but that doesn't
mean that there's not a lot going on
behind the scenes and they keep their
own counsel in terms of how many plots
do they prevent how many plots do we
know about compared to what actually
goes on and the only thing we know about
their record is when we see something
whether it's something goes wrong or
something goes right what about the
protection of individuals from the media
how often does that happen where these
people assigned to protect people
protect them from the media mm-hmm
does that go on I have some instances of
that but they're their old ones and
whether they whether there are modern
ones I don't know but I haven't heard
about them but I'll give you the flavor
of the older ones at national
conventions for example it's up to the
Secret Service to screen press
credentials for who is a valid
journalist and can get in and who can't
get in and there have been certain times
at which some journalists have charged
that this was purely a political screen
rather than a safety screen and that
that function was being used to
eliminate troublesome journalists the
and there have been lawsuits in fact
filed against the Secret Service by some
journalists for that exclusion the there
have been politicization zuv the Secret
Service but not many as far as we can
tell my I think the nadir of this comes
from the Nixon administration in which
the White House detail was told by by
the by the Nixon White House people that
when the president got heckled at a
certain demonstration they wanted
sufficient heckling so the president
looked challenged but not sufficient
heckling to drown him out and so you
would leave enough
hecklers to make it look confrontational
the president would overcome and you
you'd remove people back or heckling too
much
well you've now turned them into advance
people they're not doing protection
anymore when they're you know when they
have the heckle meter out and they're
trying to figure out if the president is
looking good or not so but but those are
rare I mean unless they are not coming
to our attention and they're going on
all the time and my suspicion is that
they're they're rare if you find this
video any pecking order or shields
usually go for local to state to federal
and if it's a military invention that we
got to put ours back and we have to
defer because I find in the acronym
agencies from Langley all the way up
there is a pecking order who does what
when it's in your jurisdiction
especially around DC the question is did
you find that there's a pecking order
between Secret Service the Langley to
Langley boys and the FBI the whole crew
when something goes down is they were
pecking order that they deferred to or
are they gonna just lump it on the
Homeland Security when it comes to
something like what you're indicating
well that's a very complicated question
I have no idea what the configuration of
Homeland Security is going to be and
what the mutual responsibility
agreements are going to be and that'll
be certainly fascinating to watch there
have been the traditional rivalries but
let me put it this way my sense is that
that the Secret Service has been
relatively neutral by federal standards
that is the contempt that the Central
Intelligence Agency has held the FBI and
over decades is well-known in in law
enforcement culture I don't get any of
that sense about the Secret Service they
seem to be just there I will say however
that the Secret Service is very
dependent on Metropolitan Police
Department's to do their work they don't
bring enough agents to Boston to take
care of everything that needs doing and
they're very they have to work with
police departments and and be very
cooperative and how to put it there's a
checkered pattern some municipalities
have a great history of cooperation with
the service and others have a really
rocky history New York City comes to
mind at least in the 1980s as being a
place where for
whatever reason and I'm not privy to
that they would end up being shouting
matches about who was going to cover a
roof and and your people aren't taking
guns up there because our people are and
all sorts of kind of productive stuff
like that but we don't we don't get to
hear much about it but again it shows
the dependency of this organization when
it goes to a foreign country it is for
better for worse very dependent on the
security forces there and whether they
are corrupt or whether they are
efficient they still have to depend on
them to a certain extent question to ask
you listen to NPR radio tonight I I was
I understood that the apply the Homeland
Security Act has a provision where
bookstores and libraries can have their
records subpoenaed by the Justice
Department to to look at what customers
are people who use the library the type
of reading the readings they do do you
think that is gonna be a useful a useful
tool in the effort to combat terrorism
provide security well I'm a bad one to
answer that question because if they
look at my list they're going to think
that I'm plotting something terrible
against the president I mean that's what
so I don't I really honestly let me say
this I think that part of the real
problem is getting the quality of data
not the quantity of data and I'm not
sure that expensive reading lists
flooding across our intelligence transom
are going to be anything more valuable
than we might have now you detailed the
evolution of the Secret Service from its
inception and it's always it seems to me
like there's a catch-22 between the
presidency and the Secret Service
president wants them to be laying low
out of public sight and yet the Secret
Service is there to do their job and to
protect the president has there always
been a fantastic marriage between the
two entities or has develop resident
that has really gotten under the skin of
the Secret Service or as the Secret
Service has turned around and said well
if you can't allow us to do our job then
they have the accusatory pointing the
fingers out one another
have you always seen it as a perfect
marriage through its inception or do you
have any good stories you could tell us
and these this does not that's a great
question but it's going to take a little
bit of a complicated answer first of all
because there are no set ground rules
the Secret Service cannot order
presidents around they can't absolutely
tell them what they have to do so that
leaves a big wedge for personality and
political style and described in the
book it's no secret secret service
agents regarded Lyndon Johnson as one of
the most abusive presidents that they
had seen he's delighted in mocking them
he delighted in pulling prankish jokes
on them and and he wasn't all that
friendly when they were around so that's
one model other presidents whose
personalities mesh more well with Secret
Service protection are not a problem and
it's really dependent so it's been it's
been a very uneven kind of evolution and
there were instances in which during the
Nixon administration they politically
had the head of the White House detail
removed for being so uncooperative in
their view of their agenda and what they
wanted to go along with so there's no
there's no predicting it let me give you
a current instance I wasn't there I'm
not privy to this but someday it'll make
an interesting Secret Service story
about what was going on in the immediate
aftermath of the terrorist attacks you
will recall that President Bush's Air
Force One detoured to several very safe
bases in the South Elmendorf Air Base
was one these are fantastically secure
locations for the Strategic Air Command
and I can almost if you'll allow me
docudrama and fill it in I can I can
hear the Secret Service saying we can't
go back to Washington because we don't
know what's going on there it's been the
site of an attack we do know that in an
underground base in Nebraska nothing is
going to happen to you so let's stay
here and the Politico is saying that may
be a good idea but the world is watching
the country needs the president back in
Washington provide leadership so so even
in a generally cooperative relationship
I mean events are going to tear this
marriage apart if if personalities and
political pressures don't
does the Secret Service have its own
forensics division once an attempt is
made like the Reagan thing and it
becomes a crime scene or does the FBI
take that over and do they have any
obligation to share what they learn with
the Secret Service if it helps them as
best I can map it together
there was a delineation agreement as
they call it which which said that at
the scene of an attempted assassination
the Secret Service's job is to get the
protectee out of there as quickly as
possible not even return fire if you
don't have to just get the protectee out
of their shield shield from bullets and
secure the scene and if you've got the
assassin hold on to the assassin until
the FBI gets there and then they're
supposed to take over I didn't see that
work letter-perfect in the attempted
assassination of President Reagan the
Secret Service agents were involved with
Hinckley and involved with the crime
scene long after the FBI should have
been there and they should have been
someplace else namely protecting the
president so so it's not really clear
but but the Secret Service does have a
forensic office of some kind my view is
that they're still dependent on the the
FBI laboratory and that's not only my
view because I never got to find out
what the forensic office does because
they never responded to me about what it
does so I don't know what it does but
they have something called forensic but
I would really doubt if it's a huge
laboratory that allows them to stand
independently of the FBI in these cases
Secret Service detection of college kids
Chelsea Clinton and the current Bush
daughters how far does that go down and
what can they do like when these girls
have social lives are always they've
gone to a sports event if they plan
south and write a sock I know in Road
races they participate well we have a
there's a chapter in the book called
Family Matters and and it refers to
first children especially first
daughters and this is a negotiate of
process again evidently I mean certainly
President Clinton had told the Secret
Service to adopt a hands-off attitude
with with Chelsea when she was attending
Stanford and but I still you know
paraphrase would you like to be the
young man dating Chelsea at Stanford
imagining your Secret Service The Secret
Service checking your record
there was this flap about the Bush twins
and their underage drinking with the
Secret Service present why didn't they
you know immediately prevent the girls
from doing this to do something well the
speculation is or the rumor is that they
were told you know let the girls be
girls and let them grow up as best they
can and you can you can watch and guard
them but try not to smother them and so
these agents had to figure out what that
meant in the context of underage
drinking at a bar so it's not clear and
and there been a lot of tensions it's
very difficult for the first children of
course and it's difficult for the agents
because there are no real rules
I wonder given the the fact that they
give their lives and they're in the line
of fire constantly you haven't mentioned
if they're well paid or is that
information that's out there I mean as
far as like as far as compared to FBI
agents or CIA agents or any information
available as yeah I mean it's it's
available on the web it's sort of
deceiving that there's starting salaries
are and GS 9 to 15 are comparable with
FBI and whatever they're under a hundred
thousand but they have overtime and
different kinds of perks I don't know
what their real remuneration is I will
say though that
I think there they are claiming to me
that they don't have a problem in a
drain of Secret Service officers going
to make more money that they all finish
out their retirement at age 55 but I
also noticed that in the in the retired
directory of Secret Service agents most
of them go on to security companies and
to provide security within companies and
you we all know those jobs are going to
pay two and three times more than
risking their life for the president so
they're they're compensated well in
terms of general federal comparisons but
but not necessarily in terms of what
they do and I was amazed at the
viciousness of the jokes against LBJ I
mean they're really nasty and her
surprised because it was a homegrown set
I've always believed that this was had
something to do with Secret Service I
lived in San Francisco during the when
Nixon was vice president and he was
speaking in San Jose for a Republican
candidate a friend of mine this was just
after the checkers speech and a friend
of mine shouted from the audience tell
us a dog story dick and I thought oh
I've always thought it was a Secret
Service who pulled him out of the
audience and down to the front for licks
and ixa to spend 20 minutes land bassing
him and telling him how disrespectful he
had been the next morning he was a naval
architect and the following morning when
he went to the gate his clearance had
been lifted and he had been fired from
the Navy that's what happened to my
friend that I'd always thought was
something you know the act that they
Secret Service that actually pulled him
out of the dog
well part of the problem is you know
there's no set line definition between
what is potentially threatening behavior
and and what is your constitutional
right and then the Secret Service comes
up against that all the time they have
been sued for trying to remove people
who claim they were just expressing
themselves and here's another thing they
run into the they don't like it when you
put your hands in your pockets of a deep
coat because of course if you have a gun
there it comes out the guns already out
as you know and so they frown on that
well there been instances in which they
end up in tussles with people who are
wearing raincoats who refuse to remove
their hands and is it your
constitutional right to keep your hands
in your pockets or is it their right to
to make those hands come out and check
for a gun so that's it's a constant or a
problem but I am the image of the CIA
has long been that it's an agency whose
culture is dominated by graduates of
elite Ivy League universities is there
any similar kind of culture that you
could identify with respect to the
Secret Service no not at all these there
are a variety of backgrounds in a
variety of training and I wouldn't say
that you know any sort of educational or
even financial elitism is anything that
I've seen in their culture and you know
if anything I think their mentality is
not that they belong to a an educational
or socio-economic elite but they see
themselves as a paramilitary corps that
that comes from all walks of life so
that it's very different thank you thank
you for your question